[Musique]
le film aux dix oscars présentée en 1939
atlanta va faire sa réapparition pour la
troisième fois en france
autant en emporte le vent n'a pas pris
une ride en quarante deux ans et
jusqu'en 1970 il était même premier au
box office du cinéma mondial
laurence périé autant en emporte le vent
le film le plus célèbre du monde est
aussi la meilleure affaire financière du
cinéma le tournage avait coûté un
million de dollars en 1938 en quarante
deux années d'exploitation
il a rapporté à la métro goldwin meyer
82 x 110 ans
numéro un au box office du cinéma
pendant plus de trente ans chaque
rediffusion est accueilli comme un
véritable événement par le grand public
[Musique]
d'abord parce que le roman est un des
romans les plus célèbres de la
littérature américaine que parce que
tout le monde a lu ce moment et que ce
roman est justement très romantique
comme il se trouve que les acteurs
correspondent exactement aux personnages
ça donne évidemment au vu d'une espèce
d'aura qui restent qui continue c'est la
même version filmée mais on a apporté
des améliorations techniques d'abord la
couleur est bien meilleure ensuite on a
changé les cadrages d'une certaine sein
même de presque toutes les scènes pour
adapter le film actuel au grand écran
donc je pense que la version est
strictement la même car c'est exactement
les mêmes acteurs les mêmes scènes mais
techniquement elle est la meilleure et
je crois que c'est la deuxième ou la
troisième fois qu'on apporte ce genre
d'amélioration pensez vous que c'est
toujours le film le plus
oh oui pour moi vous voyez
il envahit plaisir et
je pense que j'ai beaucoup de succès je
les ai vus la première fois sa première
parution et 20 euros par seconde alors
ses 40 ans potable n'est plus une fois
là et pourquoi voulez vous le voir
j'en ai de leur voir que le jeu des
acteurs pour la mise en scène pour le
tout tout la mise en scène l'acteur avec
succès
pas du tout venez voir pour la mise en
scène le projet des acteurs lochte de
plus pour l'avoir vu je sais pas c'est
parti
jean qui le cinéma si on n'a pas vu ça
manque je crois tu as des références
[Musique]